brad is your first reaction you're doing
with us and give you a couple of tips
don't talk over when people in the video
we're talking people hate that I've
experienced many a hate comment don't do
that second thing there's going to be a
screen here so don't lean in too far
even though the likes make it kind of
hard to see the laptop sometimes you
guys you're doing this you realize why
everybody wears sunglasses and interview
yeah oh yeah it's very bright you're not
gonna want to do that mellow people
what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alva I'm John Humphrey and I'm Brad
Lambert Brad are Lambert Brad are
Lambert you can follow him on Instagram
he is part of the Werner I've done a few
gigs with Warner Brothers movies I was
in movies for Warner Brothers I'm the
star of one rehearsal I did it for your
gigs like we're Central Intelligence the
gallows edge of tomorrow and Brad is
part of the team behind if I met Brad
he's part of the team that assembles all
these cool that like social media event
I know how to talk about it well done
you're doing graduates such a good job
I'm really selling what it is more
importantly forgettable on Instagram at
Brad are Lambert he deserves the
following he does photography and thank
Carol the cool stuff he goes he has like
some sexy photos of women on there I
think dear yeah he does we got a
long-ass reaction to do what you're
going to lead into like a 10 to 15
minute review most likely oh we do it
should hop into this job where are we
going to watch today we are about to
watch the first short film from oats
studios which if you've been paying
attention is the experimental short film
studio that an Neill Blomkamp and
company have sort of created it's an
open source studio so it's kind of
interactive they're going for a lot of
experimental stuff what a sci-fi factor
if you get on the steam you can even
download dailies and sound Sam let's go
add your own creativity to it so it
seems like a pretty cool thing they got
a new short film coming on Wednesday
called zygote
I believe that stars Dakota Fanning and
Jose Pablo can't eeeh but this is just
the first one this is co Rekha and
people have been loving in and since we
figured this ideas coming out on
Wednesday without any people already
asking us in advance to do a reaction
really I need to do this so we're just
like alright these are a little pretty
long short films
[Music]
racula
that's what Brad's middle name is reka
Lambert cooing - Part 1 or operator we
once mankind
hugely
[Music]
you too extreme Ania working over they
took art history and culture
we covered a man is dying humanity
the Eiffel Tower is darken security
they're building some kind of grading
facility for those that survive people
that have defected
it's worse than camp surrogate
incubators for the aliens what
they killed the leaves when we first
arrived they do these megastructures
this evening ladies actually in your
hands here
[Music]
based on their crops nothing at our
planet raving the global temperature
causing a city
they waged war set fires work forth
I'm ready hard to breathe
impossible to breathe here
[Music]
in fact humans will measure the hats
rape psyche into our minds Carolina
taking control of this recent Olympics
entry barrier it protects us from their
influence we're to assume they know we
can't produce the Nazis for everyone is
a matter of time before the entire
planet there's survivors
[Music]
created us to eat salads are better ones
[Music]
that's the future boys keep marching
forward aimlessly every rational
campuses over meanwhile this chemical is
we're through the different story by our
politician
[Music]
you
[Music]
if you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
just enough to keep
people
[Music]
before they're done for small victories
it seemed that everything humanity and
these two head
[Music]
if they arrived like Basil's carried on
the Rays of the Aurora Breanna
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
makes typical division
like Carol the Torah man here a nosh I
know those people
[Music]
this is a comment you come for me that's
reacting adapted I confess that the
world worketh mushroom and I Romania a
bomb maker but here he not only survived
he cried
I want this guy's live near the details
a cigarette falling apart is that
anything as a scavenge jump bring
anything we needed him and he knew how
many you got no we need more than that
and payment you can do the usual yeah
what about the the item and heard about
Safa sale you know my friend we need
your help you know yeah everything has a
price and we can pay it
I'm glad these [ __ ] things King you
mean that I get to burn what I see every
day every night no laws [ __ ] James
the fire fire isn't even [ __ ] fire
[Music]
incursion of life someday you see you
need myself what [ __ ] you so much fun
it's a little long
can you some big Jerry something he'll
make the booboo could take an entire
conflict and copyright or just be
inspired
interesting first English
my team live Oh people in exchange for
not an item in peace times it's not a
living thing they are yeah anything
voiceover all right
[Music]
we take zamir's interested in comparing
entre this Allstate is dead
near here rich music that I'm not gonna
hurt you
you can help Jeremy just [ __ ] kill
him
let shitty planetarium
not hurt you
all because of dollars frontman make
America's great
[Music]
so they got these two very different
traumatised characters this morning we
were sleeping
guys that defenders cut cuz they're 12
minutes sorry about that jelly go back
we're halfway through the video guys
oh she's the voiceover penis
you see you can see
that's the same offer Brad has with me
that's gorira such a good accurate of
cool ouch the same IP to teach you so
real
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
super Neill Blomkamp yeah yeah nothing
really to ourselves in these in me3 it's
leaning timing you it's not like this
out of this alien five right
I realize how funny this video would be
meaning chocolate bird [ __ ] alien come
to this country brainwash site make it
short like before don't be from doing
more of it what is it herb [ __ ]
saying your daughter is going
everyone's daughters gone the ones that
are experimented on in Cirebon the very
few porphyria it's because they have
some kind of predisposition there Sivan
some in the mirror is like that
[Music]
Iranian actress
if you're staring like that after being
under control
help us please tell me what futures
disease
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can help us decide
[Music]
yes winning the mayor
we make spider-man yeah you're right
[Music]
can you make them fear I'm here do you
remember what they did to you we do
experiments all day and all night
redditor your people
[Music]
millions I know one is not do that
[Music]
[Music]
not unlike this [ __ ] 110 million like
you device including the things giving
you an amazing power but gift beyond man
you can do the shot I feel like I do a
Martinez drop it did are Tina's good
Martinez
[Music]
they want to have to kill a man one man
down
[Music]
freecell me
what pictures we keep a lot whoa cut it
[ __ ] shoes never mind
[Music]
[Music]
come here you have to eat what they gave
you well about a little slower than 21
minutes but yeah well yeah it's like you
know a mere Eugene come Cara not Brendan
are at Carly poop Alec Gillis Noah
and yet then like a famous sexist guy in
[Music]
love this joke Oh music oh yeah all
right hopin to review what's crash done
show your respect stay till the end of
the credit unit there's no post credit
scene at least show your respect guide
people that were out got at peace hey I
mean the meantime jet like it she's
credible yeah yeah I like that talk
about more a second oats BMX let's
circle with this they want things to be
like a real film one day I mean among
other I was reading up on among other
things that they hope that eventually
some of these become feature film I mean
I know Neil Blomkamp at work in effects
and
you know experimentally for for a long
time does not show here yeah well cuz
you watch a lot of is early insurance
would fit like that in I know you did
some animations I think and all that so
[ __ ] all right well I feel like
between the three of us job will
probably have the most to say I might
have I feel like Brad and I might be
tied a little bit here wrap we fit your
breakdown really quick it was incredible
yeah visually stunning beautiful shots
in there and it was not expected I
didn't know what to what's really had no
idea what we got my did you know anyway
you didn't even see a trailer first down
there yeah it was like district nine
apocalyptic yeah it was awesome that was
the same I mean I get the impression of
like the calm is volume one so I go is
coming out on the Wednesday July twelfth
right this one was like all set as
visually impressive as it is and as
atmospheric and moody yeah it is yeah
there's yet to be a character I'm truly
hooked into but then again this is just
volume one I was doing a major set up
right now as volume one is jumping
across different pieces of the story
mean yeah this seems like it's just
laying lands for yeah yeah giving you
tastes of everything but actually Arnie
Weaver's gonna die I don't know there's
no hopped in this for me though she did
I think amazing because of her character
or is it because of Sigourney tweet I
think it doesn't it bit of a little bit
of love the right letter though yeah
because there's something about
Sigourney Weaver there's no other woman
like her no she's good you actually win
or go once a town yeah yeah should give
me badass vulnerable [ __ ] it off yeah
yeah yeah you do that
like how many woman I mean that's
nothing time and I don't even know men I
can't even say I'm lying cool you gotta
like you gotta have something to be able
to deliver that line and make it ya know
cuz she has that leaders I have quality
about oh yeah so yeah I'm definitely
drawn her and it's cool because I know
that the big deal with like neill
blomkamp was supposed to do the next
alien film and then release Cobb was
like now I want to make like 16 more
alone alien films for you and I want to
make this thing there's that everyone's
a little bit lukewarm like yeah yeah
this is one thing everyone's excited
yeah but and
we believers going to come back and
neill blomkamp thing and then they
didn't that didn't go through but now
she's in this working I was experimental
Schwartz which is just as big of a
production but in a lot of ways this is
kind of more special because this is a
baby passion project for Neill Blomkamp
I love when Big Time actors or actresses
agree to be part of a project that's
strictly out of passion they see the
potential that a potential what I'm
excited by stuff like this because I
mean as we just saw like this is super
awesome but it's also you know it's a
little independent studio that's trying
to start something new and almost you
know after after Neill Blomkamp's turn
in Hollywood you know and then having
alien 5 almost come together and not
come together like this is awesome like
to go and just be like I'm going to just
make my own thing and that's what we can
parlay that into movies later that are
yet a more my vibe like that's awesome
yeah I love what he's doing with it I'm
gonna be seen like district 9 you seen
district many I've seen Elysium yep and
chappie
yep do you like them I did yeah me too
you know kind of see that in there yeah
yeah cool it's really cool to me because
I know chappie was kind of the mix route
most mixed received what people really
don't like Chafee Berg and I we were out
there when we did I when you go back to
her old ass review of it we were like we
like it I don't see what everyone
doesn't like this really we really did
like the movie it's cool that he's
getting to do something that he doesn't
have to worry about any studio heads
like I said I didn't know anything about
this came in cold and blew me away
I mean Jamie and the storylines seemed
really compelling yeah and you did like
we're talking about Saroyan Weaver's
character and then the vo character
which actually made a physical
appearance at the end Sara yeah darris
oh yeah she did a great job on the
narration forgetter she really helps set
the bike I wonder if like Neill Blomkamp
played the music for her so she would
know the exact delivery and whatnot yeah
cause if that's way too perfect because
that music was really like Oh or the
screen is haunting man that's living is
terrible and it's like that every day
can't breathe very well yeah I even got
some terminator vibes from it - oh yeah
sort of like when Terminator one would
show footage of the resistance not like
salvation or any of those but the
Terminator one I was really getting a
strong vibe off of well yeah this has
some some ODEs to some classic sci-fi
apocalyptic stuff and then has some
things that are classic Neill Blomkamp
then add some stuff like those early
things the whole design of of their
weird like gelatinous weapon races yeah
rings and webbing buildings and even the
way the lizard alien creatures have that
stuff is kind of oozing oh yeah I'm and
you pointed out like jockeys and I went
to [ __ ] when they showed the all the
skeletons and skulls there in the
caverns below yeah yeah cuz I would
night when they were first doing that I
said predator because there's that's an
exact predator thing when the aliens you
know just like playing with the skull
and then when it drops I was like that's
not a predator
oh yeah I get in commando or a fan I
mean this ramps up that sort of
foreboding and yeah chilling you know
there's a curving yelling I've seen his
stuff in a while and and that's what
partly ya ask me about edginess series
ya know really edgy
it looks gritty and it also looks a bit
horrific yeah because this this whole
volume one is a lot of wall building
with a little bit of character building
cos like what was the second one called
- the second me I got heart Amir no I'm
here an option I'm a memory on you they
use a guy like you're warmer I will make
the call and nosh was the guy who was
smoking cigarettes and obsessed with
fire
he went from DC's legends of tomorrow
yeah he was an interesting character I
feel like I could be him in the
apartment if there's an apocalypse I
beat that guy just hanging out in his
bunker making stuff again I'd be showing
a wee into a cigarette pool where would
it be about as laid-back as Vaman oh
yeah you guys are bunkum on invention
i'll they on another big one later you
know your your burger give you some
variety lewis's there's some food like
before and you can have whatever you
want Michelle I feel like my prediction
would be Sigourney Weaver's gonna die
and I feel like a mirror they're
building him up to probably be the main
hero by the end of
because he's the one who's the most
tortured soul he was abducted got away
for some reason he had the abilities
that these aliens have I feel like
they're really building up a mirror too
because I feel like you know Blomkamp
likes to do that is like special chosen
characters he's a weapon yeah exactly
he's going to be that special chosen
weapon character well they established
that he's one of a certain kind like
these people that have what does she
come they're they're savants of some
kind that we have genetically altered so
I'm curious if we'll see more of those
you know going forward piggybacking off
your thing about Sigourney Weaver
potentially dying
I don't remember her character's name
but they shows that woman to do the
voice-over and I got it I gotta imagine
she's going to become a major character
as the ads out into a full-on narrative
story now that they've spent so much
time sending up the world the atmosphere
the mood all those things and a good
establishment of the characters that we
could probably get on board with now I'm
hoping we can get more character-driven
because it's one thing I respect about
Neill Blomkamp's films whether you like
them or not he does tend to really care
about his characters a lot yes yes and
so this one was a lot more visual what
really stylish but I'm hoping that for
the next installment especially when he
got actors at the caliber like Sigourney
Weaver and we're hearing in saigo that
Dakota Fanning's in that and I know
Michael lean supposed to appear in this
too when there's one of these that has
sharlto copley I forget Walden firebase
firebase as a cast on it too yeah he
gets people for these so I'm hoping that
now we can get a little bit more of a
stronger storyline this very much has
like a here's what we're capable of Wray
5 and I and I think it's a great place
to start but yeah I'm interested to dive
more into maybe a more focused you know
story absolutely I think we all day is
oh oh hell yes I'm all about it I think
I did get more than you I don't think so
I guess the other design thing I really
enjoyed about it was how these I think
an effective tool they're doing with the
alien creatures is maybe these
mind-warping things but however they're
doing those like clothes like slowly
panting able everything's out of focus
in the background you can't see their
eyes which makes it a million times more
scary yes that you can't actually see
they're like do they have eyeballs what
they got going little rows of black yeah
I have three or four black eye yeah yeah
so that
so really I thought that was a really
nice addition instead of like making it
really define eyeballs yeah they're
really risen reach early when they have
extra arms to and some of those wide
shots you can see like they have two
extra arm on their torso look like
alligators
yeah like weird bug alligators they all
said the vibe of the creatures in
Suicide Squad
oh that's sort of yeah that weird like
resin II kind of thing yeah yeah really
cool texture and color - yeah with the
great thing that Warner Bros over text
oh yeah I can't wait to watch the rest
of them Thank You Brad for being here
thanks for having me guys I just love
your hair you look like Jared Leto I
said Jon Hamm the baby driver - oh yeah
yeah I'll take both at the same time
you're the love child of this with the
personality of Daniel Radcliffe that's
what you're come on Brad Radcliffe know
that Radcliffe Lambert I'm never gonna
remember what the are actually stands
for we all right Robert
that that's too complicated hey guys you
can watch this video there's a link at
the description box to watch it in full
screen instead of just a box right here
watch on your TV watching our TV I would
like to watch this on the TV I would
like to watch it something instead of
ours I can take a laptop we have here if
they did some kind of special screening
I would be all done I would go to with
the arrow just like yeah yeah you're
part of life that'd be cool subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
belt used at John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
Blum house.com
but beyond any of that crap what I care
most about is that you follow Brad
Lambert at our Lambert on Instagram and
still at Brad our Lambert where he has
photos not mainly of himself but awesome
photography he does there's some hot
girls in there some good environment
shots yeah we got a pretty some cool
stuff we got a produce we should do some
actual video content together feel like
you could just teach me how to
photograph
he also is in charge a lot of the social
media stuff on Warner Brothers they're
the best you're gonna get out of yes the
measure your kid and he's my new acting
manager I have declared it he told me
five minutes ago yeah guys are here for
that it's all about who you know and I
know who you know and I know the record
yeah every other page man check it out